wir sind hier in der west ukraine
unterwegs und sind gestern über land
gefahren und haben da ein altes
verlassenes gebäude gefunden in dem sich
ausländische freiwillige kämpfer hier
sammeln und auf ihren einsatz im krieg
in der ukraine vorbereiten wo das genau
ist haben wir versprochen nicht zu
verraten und auch möglichst keine
anhaltspunkte darauf zu geben weil hier
im westen der ukraine jetzt bereits sehr
große angst vor russischen spionen ist
eben verdacht stehen eben hier
militärische ziele auszukundschaften
weil jederzeit mit luftangriffen
gerechnet wird
es ist so dass man hier an der grenze
schon merkt als ich über die grenze
gefahren bin auch dass in den zügen in
den bussen über all diese jungs zu sehen
sind die mit dem großen druck säcken
kommen ich habe auch mit einem
gesprochenen der amerikaner der der zwei
jahre militärdienst gemacht hat und aber
nur auf einer basis in lousiana rumsas
und meinte jetzt hat er das gefühl
endlich mal etwas machen zu können und
das verwenden zu können was er gelernt
hat um etwas gutes zu tun
das war ganz verschiedene leute da sind
viele briten und viele amerikaner war
auch georgier deutsche aus allen
möglichen ländern die sich daher gerade
sammeln und versuchen strukturen
aufzubauen
die ukraine versuchen jetzt über diese
ganzen netzwerke kontakte die sie auch
mit mit den alten freiwilligen verbänden
aus dem don was krieg haben das in
irgendeiner form in ihre streitkräfte zu
integrieren also wir haben ja neben der
armee diese territorial kräfte aufgebaut
und aber man merkt das ist alles noch
sehr improvisiert ist also dass sie es
gibt auch keine auch dabei die versuchen
dieser diese kontakte zu intensivieren
und strukturen aufzubauen aber das ist
alles noch ganz am anfang
wir haben gesagt dass wir auch sehr
genau schauen was das für leute sind
also dass
sie keine vorstrafen haben dass sie vor
allem keine wenn ich aus irgendeinem
neonazi hintergrund haben weil das eben
die sorge ist dass sich da die die
falschen leute ihnen anschließen
das meinten gerade die briten mit denen
wieder angesprochen haben dass es ihnen
extrem wichtig ist die leute erstmal
vorzubereiten und und eben diese
strukturen zu bilden weil sie sagen dass
man den ukrainern im prinzip mehr
schadet als nützt wenn westliche
abenteurer mit mit ihrer ausstattung die
sie sich gekauft hat mir reinkommen und
und dann irgendwo anfangen zu kämpfen
weil sagen viel wichtiger wäre es
eigentlich dass sie ihre ausrüstung der
den den ukrainischen kämpfen geben die
wirklich sich hier auskennen die wissen
was zu tun ist wenn wir sagen dass das
30 bis 40 tausend ich weiß nicht ob
soldaten oder in den ganzen anderen
verbänden hier den falls sie sprachen
von 30 bis 40 1000 kämpfern die die eben
nicht mehr über helme und schutzwesten
verfügen und das bitter nötig hätten
was bei all diesen leuten
sehr stark zu spüren war war die die
extreme anspannung dass sie versucht
haben cool zu wirken aber aber in doch
sehr sehr bewusst war wo sich hier wo
sie sich befinden und wo sie sich heran
begeben haben es war dann nur
zwischendurch mal einmal haben sie für
uns foto tatsächlich auch posieren
wollen mitmischen frage und slava
ukraine zusammengerufen und darum
geflachst aber zwischendurch merken dass
jeder bis in die letzte szene eigentlich
angespannt ist und keiner weiß was jetzt
erwarten wird
[Musik]